[Music]
people who are masks they're driven by
trauma they're obsessed with justice
because of some injustice they suffered
ergo the mask it hides the pain I wear
the mask to protect myself right
I'm the pain there was a Calvary
involved shooting last night
you're gonna give me the speech now what
speech I should calm down take a breath
or we're organic no there's a guy in my
trunk
delightful put him in the pod you know
why you're here
some done kicked in like don't put me in
trouble on our [ __ ] car that is
correct
fella my lawyer yeah we don't have to do
that the terrorists
why would they start this [ __ ] up again
maybe there was something he didn't want
to fail they had a mission
I only just forgot the cavalry has our
names and addresses
I was like oh please please fast minutes
is conspiracy torture the headlights
what is this
it's the only way to show you the truth
he's helped stop the seventh Cavalry
doing what those [ __ ] trying to start
a war
[Music]
well it looks like you got things under
control here full costume Thanks
[Music]
[Music]